I'm anti-mandate for sure you know and
you know my wife's a doctor I'm pretty
okay reliably convinced that vaccines
have been a good thing overall in in the
world
um I yeah you know I I I'm not a
scientist this is one of the reasons why
I stayed away from the story is because
this is not my ex area of expertise but
um I I do think lockdowns have been bad
uh I do think the the Press
lied about the threat to kids and I
don't understand why they had to do that
um I'm not I'm not so sure about the
efficacy of vaccinating children at all
you know this recent Missouri V Biden
case involves some doctors who just said
some very logical things like if there's
any risk at all with this vaccine even
if it's infinitesimal it's probably more
than the risk of sending your kid to
school